I have had management to tell me stop
harping on this topic Pearl bring people
together you want to have a broader
appeal broader audience but I just don't
care I just really I don't care because
I think that we should fight for truth
and we should fight for being honest and
trick now guys when I started my journey
I really had it more drag on mindset
that was like my I would say beginning I
watched Peterson I watched Ben Shapiro
et cetera et cetera but the issue with a
lot of track comes they're definitely
better than the lips all right that's
just better than the lids but they
default to egalitarianism they tell
women we're more special than we are and
they they're very big into the not all
but